So let's review how we got to where we are right now.
In 1789 you have the Revolution in France.
This makes the French very proud, a lot of nationalistic pride.
It also makes the rest of Europe a little worried.
They're all monarchies, they don't like this idea of overthrowing your kings.
And so during this revolutionary period you have a series of wars with the rest of Europe.
Revolutionary France does, essentially, the French Revolutionary Wars.
And during that period Napoleon becomes quite famous as the French
and maybe the best European military commander.
So, now Napoleon is starting to become essentialy a hero in France.
And by 1799 he is able to come to power in a coup d'état
with a couple of other people and then he outmaneuvers them
and then by 1804 he becomes the emperor Napoleon
and in this whole period he is now trying to expand the Empire
so these were the Revolutionary Wars, and these you can consider right over here
are the Napoleonic Wars and the pic of the French Empire under Napoleon
happens in 1812 and the real downfall
if you ask my opinion and many other people
would be when he invaded Russia
that really decimated the French Grand Armée
and we saw in the last video that by April 1814,
the 6th coalition was finally succesfull against Napoleon
and then he was exiled
to the island of Elba where we're taking up the story
he only hung out there for a little under 10 months
he was separated from his family
so that even though he was put in charge of this litle island
it wouldn't have been what he wanted
and he obviously was an ambitious person on top of that
He caught wind of what was happening in France.
Louis the 18th was there, the nobility returned
they weren't treating the old Army veterans well which made him suspect
that he may be able to retake control somehow
On top of that the French Empire
was being shrunken back to its original boundaries
which made many people in France a lot less proud so Napoleon
started to sense that maybe he could do something.
On top of that, he caught wind that people might not
leave him in Elba because he is Napoleon and they were afraid that he may come back
so they might banish him to someplace even more remote,
or there might be some attempts to assassinate him
So with that in mind, being who he is, and being as creative as he is
he's able to somehow escape from Elba, he's able to get a boat,
land on the Southern shores of France. The French
authorities are able to catch wind of this, they send the military
to engage with him, this is the French military
to essentially confront
capture, kill Napoleon on the Southern shores of France
and when he sees them, he dismounts from the horse that he's got,
he walks up to them completely unarmed and he says,
"go ahead, shoot your emperor"
which is in my mind a fairly gutsy move to do
And they rally around him and he's able to actually take control
of the army that was sent to capture or kill him
and he starts marching to Paris
He starts marching to Paris, and Louis the 18th, the brave man that he is
catches wind of this and escapes
and so by March of 1815 Napoleon is able to retake control
of Paris and essentially, France.
And this is the beginning of what is known as the Hundred Days.
It actually is about a 111 days, but it doesn't sound that good.
So between March 1815, and July 1815
You can imagine, even before Napoleon was able to reach Paris
word got around about what was going on
That Napoleon was back, they didn't like it
They essentially announced that they wouldn't stand by there
and that were going to form a new coalition to stop him
So Napoleon had two options once he gets in Paris,
He could essentially sit and wait
wait for the combined forces of Europe to reorganize and then attack him.
Or he could go on the offensive,
he could attack before they had a chance to fully regroup
you can imagine, he viewed this as being his best shot
so he starts going after the combined forces of Great Britain
and Prussia in what is now Belgium
And over there is where he engaged in probably some of the most
decisive battles, the most decisive one was the battle of Waterloo
which is possibly one of the most famous battles in history
maybe due to also the Abba song about it
and that is where he met the Duke of Wellington on the British side,
and Blücher on the Prussian side
Napoleon had seventy or eighty thousand troops
The other side had a hundred and twenty/thirty thousand troops
A extremely bloody battle, more than forty/fifty thousand people killed,
injured, missing on and on and on.
But in the end, Napoleon lost and many historians,
there's different reasons for why he lost
he actually did a pretty good job considering the scenario
the ground because of the weather was very muddy
and actually was not good for being on the offense
It was very good conditions for being on the defense
And you know, Napoleon was essentially trying to take out
these somewhat remnant armies before the Coalition,
the 7th Coalition essentially had a chance to fully get back to full force
But he loses at Waterloo, there are a few skirmishes after that,
but the French retreat back to Paris
At this point Napoleon sees the writing on the wall
He's not completely delusional
He sees that if they were able to, especially if the Prussians
are able to get him again, they might not let him live
They might really do something crazy
with him, so he surrenders himself to the British
And then they exile him to the isle of Saint Helena
which is one of the very remote island which is afraid to be exiled to
to begin with. An just to give a sense of how remote it is
This right over here
is the South West coast of Africa
This is Africa right over here.
Saint Helena is right out over here
Almost in the middle of the Atlantic
between Africa and South America
And that's where Napoleon would
live out the rest of his life
In a very uncomfortable situation
much worse than what he had going on in Elba
Separated from everyone else.
And then he dies in 1821
The official cause and this is what many historians
do believe actually happened
Is that he died of stomach cancer
Bu there are many theories that there might
have been some type of assassination
Some slow arsenic poisoning
There was a lot of arsenic in his tissues
His body was unusually well preserved after his death
That's one of the things arsenic does
Some people think that it might have been
an inadvertent arsenic poisoning
because of the environment that he was in
Of the conditions he might have been in,
of the paint in the walls,
but either way, he really lived roughly
throught the last six years
in pretty unpleasant conditions, and then
died of stomach cancer.
And that was essentially the final end of Napoleon